i'm dave rubin and this is another
friday reuben report
panel extravaganza today we'll be
talking about the dystopian state of
california
and the upcoming recall of our governor
gavin newsom i'm very excited
joining me today are host at the
washington examiner alicia krauss
former ambassador to germany and former
acting director of national intelligence
rick grinnell
and author of i'm your emotional support
animal
and host of the adam corolla show adam
carolla
guys welcome to the reuben report thank
you thanks for having us
all right you're all in la but corolla
you were the only one
born in california so i'll let you start
what do you make of the state of this
place
this dystopian place that we live in
i may not only be the only one amongst
us who was born in california i may be
the only
person that was born in california
because i've never met
anyone except for dr drew my girl
in anyone uh over 30 i should say
okay um you know i always look at
california
as a beautiful blonde in high school who
just kind of got by in her looks
and always had a date and never had to
study and life was
pretty good and now that blonde is 46
and has some crow's feet and
actually needs to do something and
the thing is is like hey we got the
ocean we got the mountains
we got malibu we got disneyland even if
it's shuttered
so we don't really have to do anything
because we're so attractive
you know what i mean like they don't
have to hustle like other states with
bad weather
and bad topography so they've got to
kind of earn it whereas we've always
just went like hey we'll just hang
around we'll just flutter our
eyelashes and the boys will come to us
and we're getting a little long in the
tooth and we're not as attractive
as we used to be and the boys are
leaving for texas and florida
yeah well now she's got a drug-addicted
homeless guy living under her dress
right not as appealing uh alicia you
moved here what eight years ago
from from the middle of this great
country why are you still here
i gotta say i think for me you know my
husband and i
are practicing evangelical christians
and for us
we currently feel like our purpose and
our calling is to be here and to raise
our girls here
um they're of the ages 11 to 18 months
there's four of them i'm homeschooling
because knew some of the teachers unions
don't care about our schools but we can
get to that in a moment
they don't care about our schools or our
kids and so for us
to uproot we kind of the motto that
we've said and i respect everyone's
individual decisions and kind of
uh risk assessment that they're taking
but we didn't want to
flee in fear and we didn't want to stay
because of pride and we are very plugged
into our local community and our local
church my husband is a business owner
here in the state
and um we wanted to be able to
potentially make a difference
and we feel like if we just leave we're
not going to be able to change anything
in this state and
i mean jerry brown once infamously said
it as goes california so goes the rest
of the nation and i'd like to hopefully
shift california
so that that is a positive thing and not
negative for the rest of the nation
yeah well for the record and my audience
has heard me say this before
i want to stay and fight that's why i'm
so thrilled about gavin being recalled
but you know your buddy michael knowles
over at the daily wire
i had him over for dinner he agreed with
me that we were both going to stay we
said we're going to stay
and fight and then the next morning the
daily wire announced that they were
moving to nashville so i got a deal
i got to do that things wrong there one
michael knowles is my buddy
and then two to even trust him or
anything that comes up
fair enough uh rick i know how much you
loved california like you
i i know you personally were friends
like you love california you love
l.a you love the desert you love the
beaches you've been here forever
does it have a chance does it have a
chance to turn around
it has to have a chance here's the
problem is if you leave california you
find yourself
in not california and that's a worse
worst state of affairs i just love this
state
and we've got a we got to do something
to fight back
i went to elementary school in redwood
city and back then
san francisco bay area or as we used to
say
uh we lived between san francisco and
san jose
and now it's just the entire bay area
and it's a shell of what it once was
we've got to keep up and we've got to be
able to support the middle class the
people who
love california who are here not because
they're a hollywood star
or they didn't get uh you know a
technology that that got them
to be billionaires and so now they live
in the hollywood hills there's a whole
bunch of people that make california
great and i have to say that i don't
believe i'm not one of these people that
believe that anyone
in in california and the majority is
partisan
i think the majority of people are not
partisan we're so far away from
washington
we just always try to be at the cutting
edge
and want to do something different and
that's why i think
they are leading the nation with getting
rid of the governor
who has had him on lockdowns more than
any other governor
across the country yeah as we're
recording this right now i just read
this morning that we are now the last
state when it comes to reopening gyms so
they i mean they don't even want us it's
not they don't want us going out to eat
and seeing each other
they also want us i guess fat and
and unhealthy adam why is it we've
talked about this before i actually want
all of your opinions on this but adam
why is it that people in california as
someone that's lived here your whole
life
cannot seem to uh grasp the concept
that the people that they vote for have
something to do with the bad policies
that they are surrounded by they hate
the schools they keep voting people
they hate the homeless situation they
keep voting for people that bring these
things the drugs
the whole thing why can they not make is
it the sun it's just too much sun and
they've been fried
yeah i think there's some delusion
going on but i think a lot of it
started when we started getting into the
real ad hominem stuff where we were like
you people on this side of the aisle are
bad people you're not
people we disagree with we do disagree
with you
but you're also bad people and
our people are good people so
when you have your people who you've
labeled as good people
doing bad things you just become
like this mom who's a horrible mom but
you go but she loves her kids but she
loves you know she loves those kids and
it's like
right but she's feeding them crap for
breakfast
the house is a mess there's no insurance
there's no alarm
her car isn't insured i know but she
loves she loves
those kids so i believe if they removed
all these sort of good and bad from the
equation
and they just went look just brass tacks
here's what these
people are doing here's what these
people are suggesting
then we could do it because as long as
you think
your side is good or virtuous then
you're just going to vote for your side
no matter
what they do and what they do is bad
so in a one-party state alicia how do we
convince people that always voting to
raise taxes
is probably not great for business
i mean adam is inspiring me with all of
his analogies although i wish he'd use
a male analogy every once in a smile but
it almost reminds me
you know piggybacking on what he's
saying in their opinions you know
they're always
chirping i'll do a male one
i it almost reminds me to what he was
saying it's almost like a parent that is
enabling the drug abuser it's like well
if i give them more money maybe they'll
help themselves one of these days
instead of the tough love
and i think that people really with the
recall news and i think
uh credit to the awful pandemic that
we've all lived through thank goodness
and we have the t-shirts to show it
that this has really been a bipartisan
issue of frustration
in the overreach of government and
definitely
with regards to the hypocrisy of
government and so i think that
i even have hardcore leftist friends and
people in hollywood that are definitely
leaning to the left that are messaging
me oh yeah i signed the petition but i'm
afraid i'll be outed or i donated to the
recall effort but i'm afraid i'll be
outed as we've seen with some of the
other people that were funding the
effort
i think that we're at a breaking point
and i am hopeful
even though some of what i'm seeing is
only anecdotal personal experience
that people are realizing all right we
need to be engaged we need to be
involved because you also see people
on the other side of the aisle that tend
to only vote for the you know president
vote for a couple of props here and
there where they maybe saw sophia bush
in an ad talking about how to help the
children
and then they ignore the down ballot uh
races that are crucial because politics
is local and what is affecting your
local schools
are the people that you're you know
voting for here at the supervisor level
whether or not you can open restaurants
et cetera et cetera so i think that this
is
a an example in a basic case and how our
education system has failed people of
completely understanding how government
works
and hopefully this is a wake-up call for
them to realize that they need to get
involved
so if the wake-up call doesn't happen at
least at like the super
local level rick you've been probably as
outspoken on
on getting rid of newsome as anybody do
you think well hey
it sounds like there there are the votes
right we know that we already have
or there are enough signatures we know
that we have over 1.5 million
they're going to contest some of them so
the goal is probably to get 1.8 or 1.9
so that it happens
but do you think the people will have
woken up enough to go oh
we shouldn't just vote him right back in
after we recall him we got to actually
find somebody else
well guys i think first of all let's be
honest we're going to need
well over 2 million because the the
entire system this is a one-party system
and we've got a brand new secretary of
state she's never been involved at all
in these issues and she was just placed
there by gavin newsom
and now she's going to be in charge of
collecting all of these
uh signatures validated from the
counties
so there's going to be a whole bunch of
game playing gavin has already announced
that a mail in ballots
mail ballots will be sent to everybody
on the voter list
now i can tell you those voter lists are
atrocious
and that's why they want to send a
ballot to every single person
on that list because in california we
move a lot
people are transient that list is
crap and i can tell you that's crap
because in los angeles county
they sent two ballots to my neighbor's
parents who had been
dead for 10 years and 12 years and the
twitter
community relations people what did they
do
rather than say wow don't you think we
should contact los
angeles county and tell them that
they're sending ballots to dead people
no they kicked me off twitter for two
days because i shared the information
they shot the messenger
as community relations people so big
tech
is now working to mess this whole system
up
mail ballots to people who don't know
they're coming ask yourself why
ohio and florida 60 percent of the
people
did mail-in ballots and there were
virtually no
problems and that's because you have to
request
the ballot we are all for mail-in
ballots
but if you live somewhere you need to
tell the county what your
address is and that you want the ballot
so you know it's coming
then we can have mail-in ballots this
reckless system that gavin just signed
off on
of mailing ballots out to the current
voter rolls the current voter rolls are
a mess and this is just
asking for fraud and it's going to be
the way that he can
figure out a way to stay in office this
is really outrageous
yeah well look i don't want to get off i
don't want to get kicked off youtube or
twitter but david and i got
mail-in ballots to our old address that
we had moved it moved from months before
and then we voted from our new address
but we didn't even have to show id i
mean you
i actually took my id out thinking you
have to do something and the guy was
like no no put that away
um adam adam you think uh you think
they're going to get them
you tweet about your frustrations with
this place every day
you think you think something could
actually turn with newsome
it would be nice um for me
one of my greatest laments is how
passive
all the citizens have become how sort of
sheep like how
the government just sort of says jump
and we just sort of say how high
i i am you know the fact that it's been
a year and
businesses are still shuttered and
schools are still shuttered and
i'm not hearing an uprising or pushback
so
you know i think to me the real
disappointment
isn't in the government i don't really
trust the government i feel like they're
just doing what they're
here to do which is bigger more control
more power
over you and a bigger part of your life
and telling you
what to do i'm really devastated
and kind of shocked and surprised that
the people
haven't stood up and said enough is
enough this is the united states this is
not how we roll
and to take it a step further not only
are they not stepping up
they're trying to cancel out people who
do step
up which is now we're getting into some
weird orwellian territory so
if the people would just be
a little more pragmatic and a little
less you know
visceral or use their head instead of
their heart a little bit
and realize what is going on in this
state
and how it just gets progressively worse
every year
and step up and vote
vote let's just be a little more
pragmatic let's just use
math let's just use math instead of our
heart or compassion or empathy or all
this bs that everyone
bandies about i've never heard more talk
about empathy
from politicians but they know they're
dealing with dumb people in california
who are very married to these to these
themes so for me i wish the people would
just step up
admit they were wrong you made a mistake
you voted for gavin newsom
he is an imbecile and there's something
wrong with him
he doesn't his synapses don't fire he's
either pathological liar or he doesn't
con
his vessels don't contain blood or
whatever you want to say about him
you idiots of california made a mistake
and you voted for an imbecile
now right this ship admit you were wrong
and go another direction
just for the record have any of the
three of you ever spent fifteen
thousand dollars on wine during a
pandemic at the most expensive
restaurant in the united states
just two times but i know corolla has
but
you know he's a big hollywood star rick
you're a public servant you've never
done that have you
i've never spent 15 000 on wine
during the bustling times of this
you know economy no that it's ridiculous
i'm way too cheap for that i would never
do that
um the guy in the costco wine section
might know me by my first name but i
have never spent that much on wine
before
so so alicia to adam's point what what
i'm kind of worried about because it is
a one-party state is that there is just
there is just a true culture of fear in
that
people like i was just in florida for
the last 10 days people were happy
people were out and about i was in
restaurants where there were 85 and 90
year olds a lot of old people in florida
and they were
having dinner and making decisions for
themselves but that the culture of fear
around here
so many people afraid to let their dogs
now say hi to each other
like that that thing is that is more
scary to me than the policies in a way
that the
people literally my neighbor like three
houses over had a had a baby shower
10 or 15 people there and some a
neighbor called the police on them that
that is the thing that we have to fear
in a weird way more than the stupid
policies of mr
synapses aren't working newsom you know
anything though i appreciate that it now
lets me know like the level of
brainpower that someone does or does not
have like if i see somebody driving down
the road and they're in their car by
themselves and they're not
asked with their windows up i'm like you
know what we ain't going to be friends
but when i see somebody on a hike and
they don't have a mask on and i don't
have a mask on it's like you do
this little head nod like you're logical
i'm logical we should be friends
and i think unfortunately that silencing
culture that you just referenced or that
fear culture that you just referenced
has come from a lot of time the rich and
the powerful
that are um you know running fashion
running finance running the tech
industry
running social media and running
hollywood and i
hope that there's going to be a hope
small
but silent and even mighty um level of
people in the state that rise up and say
no we're not going to put up with this
crap anymore
and i don't know once again this is
anecdotal but i'm seeing
the restaurant association push back i'm
seeing public school teachers that are
against the unions that are starting to
push back on social media
i'm seeing parents that are saying hey
you know what are we going to do with
our kids how
come private schools can do this well
but public schools cannot um that are
asking these questions
you're you're seeing restaurants that
decided to remain open like joe's down
in redondo beach
and fight against the l.a county health
department and got
tons of support from the local community
i went down there and 80
of the crowd were registered democrats
invited voters
and so i think i see hope in those
instances of true humanity saying
government get out of our way shut up
and let us do what we need to do for the
betterment of ourselves and our families
and i think agreeing with adam i wish it
would spread but even as it does
the mainstream media is not going to
cover it because it goes against the
narrative of fear that they are trying
to spread
yeah rick you must love that that last
portion of what she said there
because you know i went to a whole bunch
of uh
of trump rallies in beverly hills and
obviously you were in the administration
and
you were out on the campaign trail for
trump there were a ton of people that i
met that were not republicans they were
not conservatives
they were these were apolitical people
or they were restauranteurs mugged by
reality or something like that
that i actually do think maybe there's a
chance that it wouldn't just be
that he would get replaced by some other
you know sort of
whacked out progressive but maybe a a
guy like rick grinnell
what do you think look i i think every
everybody's frustrated in california no
matter where you go my every you know
neighbor that i have is a liberal i have
great friends who are
on the left i have friends very close
friends who campaign for gavin newsom
who are now collecting
signatures to recall because they
realize
that he has mismanaged from a political
standpoint just his pure
management uh you know tactics
are what's convincing people that he's
not up to the job i mean
let alone you know we don't have a
timber industry and we have forest fires
we
keep telling people to conserve water we
live on the ocean
we do we are you know the california has
no
lng terminal think about that we have
exploded
liquid natural gas natural gas industry
to the point where it's transformed our
economy and we've got no
terminal in all of california because
the governor thinks
that somehow it's bad and therefore
we're not
able to participate in the lng explosion
and sell
to china which would also help on
climate issues
so we now are seeing liberals
who say this governor doesn't know what
he's doing
but i think adam's point is a good one
is that everybody silently
doesn't like this guy and sees the
mismanagement and sees the homelessness
but then they they're not speaking up
yes
when you're mugged by reality and you
own a restaurant you do
or you have kids that are in the
government controlled schools and your
neighbors go to catholic schools and
you're like wait a minute
why are they going and my kids in the
government schools don't get to go
so i would say if we could just tell
people to speak up and
say what's on your mind whether you're
liberal conservative
declined to state whatever you are if
you
feel that gavin newsom has mismanaged
the state you are not alone speak up
adam you're the big hollywood star here
what do we do about all your hollywood
friends
you know i think we have
instilled such a climate of fear
and we have shown so many examples
of people being canceled that these
people
who who aren't the most heroic uh
by nature to start with you know they're
not firefighters or loggers they're
actors you know so most of them have a
nice yellow streak running down their
spine from birth
and now we're asking those people to
jeopardize their career because the left
has done a wonderful job
of silencing people you know it's sort
of like
what they what the left did is they do
one of those movies
like in those movies like die hard or
something where they have all the people
hostage and uh
the bad guy the heavy like walks in and
he points at the secretary and he goes
come here i want to tell you something
and then he just puts a bullet in her
head and she falls to the ground
and they go okay any more questions so
we saw that one person
drop that now that's enough to keep the
other 30 people in
in line in that room except for it's not
one person it's
every day we see somebody new canceled
in hollywood from the bachelor host to
gina carano
whoever i mean the list is too long for
us to remember so
the left has done a fantastic job
in silencing people because they've
removed them from their livelihood
and it's despicable and obviously the
same people that never stopped
bloviating
about mccarthyism are the ones that are
just sort of
sitting silently by the sidelines right
now
but it's been an incredibly effective
tool and the only way it's going to work
i mean i always sort of look at it this
way which is
if you are in a prison camp and there's
three guards with machine guns
and you want to rush them individually
at 30 second intervals you're all going
to die
eventually if you all just bum rush them
at the same time most of us are getting
out of here
some of us are going to get shot but our
only
shot is the full gang bum rush and so
i think as people sort of come out they
send their tweets out there they make
their opinions known
they get picked off one by one but if
there was just a
wave a ground swell of this
they couldn't pick anyone everyone off i
mean
you look think about something like
scientology i was doing
radio in 1999 and i said some horrible
stuff about scientology
everyone told me oh they're going to
destroy you they will destroy you
scientology would destroy you but
once a enough people came first off you
realize they're paper
tigers there's no teeth there but once
now everyone
comes up and rises up against
scientology and there's nothing they can
do
but if you do it individually they can
pick you off one by one
adam have you ever thought that maybe
they were playing the 25-year game
they're on yeah it's the slow game
they're coming after me yeah i mean
that what's going on with the
d-platforming
and the cancel culture is you guys
really have to think about scientology
25 years ago the deal was like everyone
knows the crackpots
everyone wants to say something but you
say something because they will destroy
you
and everyone just sat silently alicia
since you mentioned
you have you have young kids uh although
they're they're not being taught all the
woke stuff just yet at that age i
seriously hope that and you're teaching
them at home
yeah and home school what are you what
are you hearing though from your friends
that have young kids that are
that are in the schools because every
day i see something on twitter where
it's like you know white kids being
taught that they're bad and we want
equity not equality
and all the usual stuff and even though
public schools here aren't open
specifically in the bay area and
uh lausd where we live and have most of
our friends
um there's the the promised land of
orange county as my husband likes to
call it
it seems the most normal place ventura
other counties for those outside of la
that's an
area just us and just south of us
beautiful coastal areas
more normal people and conceal and carry
permits um
but i am hearing a lot of frustration
from parents that they'll walk in
on their kids and the teacher is just
doing stuff on
zoom or complaining about uh covet
regulations
but not about the reopening about
wanting to remain closed
um telling the kids to double mask
telling them not to visit their
grandparents
like before christmas a girlfriend of
mine whose girls are at a very swanky
private school here in los angeles said
she walked in on her first grader
and the teacher was telling her that it
would be selfish to go see her grandma
for christmas
i'm sorry but if i'm paying here that's
only your business to tell my kid
anything outside of teaching them
reading writing and arithmetic so
unfortunately it's not just a public
school problem it's a
secular school problem and uh i think
that parents need to definitely explore
i'm a thousand percent a fan of school
choice and i think that the california
republican party
and california and republican
politicians nationwide
are being very remiss to not latch on to
the school choice issue right now
because it is something that polls
incredibly well even with democratic
minority women in this state
because every woman in the country cares
about her children
yeah although oddly uh elizabeth warren
and many other democrats who send their
children to private schools they don't
like school choice isn't that it's so
weird how these guys do that
um all right before i let you guys go
look so everyone gets it cali's a mess
florida's great we all get it everyone's
fleeing san francisco and moving to
miami and hopefully they don't ruin
miami like a pack of locusts
but we shall see rick i'll do you first
are you going to run
are you going to run i want you to run
i'm saying it out loud i say it on
twitter all the time
will you run for governor and save
california
look um this is a long answer but
i i think what alicia said about school
choices is such a big issue
and it's fundamentally rooted in in some
of our problems in california i have
launched
this organization called fix california
and it's doing three things long term
and so i i we can talk about it all day
but but just to answer your question
i think that too many people have
abandoned california
and not tried to fix and do the
long-term thing so i'm committed to
doing the long-term
things i've said i i'm not going to
think about running for governor in 2022
i think it's it's a
you know you're not going to win in
california as a republican unless we fix
the system
and the three things that i'm doing with
fix california should fix the system if
we can get them accomplished in five
years
so 2022 is out let's see what happens
when we get
uh signatures if we get signatures and
if they don't play games on a recall
all right i appreciate the long game but
i guess that means i have to look to
corolla now corolla you're going to run
uh somebody actually brought that up to
me uh earlier today that there's some
group that was uh interested uh
it's a funny thing because i would never
think of myself as a politician and
never in a million years would ever run
for something but you know a few years
ago i didn't think of myself as a
documentarian or an author or any of
that stuff so
who knows and possibly one day even gay
the uh the
the day is gone who knows
wait for me yeah um you know my thing is
like
i don't have hard fast
answers for things i'd like i will hear
what people have to say and if it seems
to make sense
i i will definitely think about it i
mean it
it seems insane but what's been
happening is the more
shows i do like your own but even like
tmz
when i'm done explaining what we need to
do the host just pauses and goes why
don't you run for governor
yeah yeah so i'm sort of like uh arleigh
ermey
arleigh ermey gunny miss that guy man
i miss our lee ermey but he was the
he was the uh drill sergeant
in full metal jacket and
he originally was signed on
to work as an advisor to the film
you know so he was saying to the actor
who's playing the drill sergeant now say
it like this and uh
you know your last easy day was
yesterday after a while the director
just went well why don't you just do it
and that's how we got the part so for me
and governor it's kind of like
i'm sitting around telling everyone how
to fix everything and what we need to do
and how it should work and
who would be a good person but at some
point i think some people are looking at
me going
well then why don't you just do it if
you're the one with all the answers so
maybe wow corolla i'm very pleased
i i i don't know what to say i'll
endorse you right this second
uh alicia i'm gonna guess that you're
not gonna run but can you
take us out with a with a pleasant
overview of the future
perhaps under governor corolla
under oh under governor corolla that
would be amazing and now we just need a
republican or
a competent person with a brain who
cares about schools and homelessness and
health here
as mayor of la that'd be nice yeah small
steps
uh we'll see if that happens well
i am uh i always try to end these with a
little hopeful something but crowley you
just gave it to me there's a chance so
you're saying there's a chance that
that's all i ask for rick you're gonna
play the long game
alicia will keep staying and fighting uh
i thank you guys oh
and more importantly than anything we've
said here if you haven't signed the
recall yet
and you live in california you can't do
it online they make this thing as
difficult
as possible go to recallgavin2020.com
where you can find out where you can
actually have to do it by hand
and rick you know all about this they're
very specific if your pen
touches the line then that doesn't count
follow the rules
follow the rules it's so bananas i
signed it in a huge crowd at a rally
and it's like if literally if your pen
touches the line they they won't count
it but somebody has to hold the thing
for you because you can't be indoors
so it's all crazy but recall
gavin2020.com
i thank you guys and hey we got a chance
corolla i'm gonna uh
i'm gonna sign up on godaddy for your
campaign website and then i'll charge
you later
thanks dave you'll be the minister of
smoked meats in my cabinet
i can do that i can do that all right
thank you guys
thanks guys